[Musique]
pourquoi décor aussi l'emballage était
au tennis j'ai commencé par le tennis et
je me sentais un peu seul mon professeur
de sport au collège ma
un mac du jeu vous rendre m'a dit de
venir à l'est de là il ya un entraîneur
qui est venu me chercher du club de
versailles jean luc godard j'ai trouvé
ça super sympa d'avoir un groupe de
potes et voilà c'était super sympa de
perdus on avait des copains et ça fait
maintenant presque maintenant
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir assez compliqué
mais ce qu'il ya la montée avec plaisir
qui était attendu depuis de nombreuses
années par bon nombre de supporters et
je crois que c'est les larmes de
quelques-uns qui m'ont marqué et je
pense que je veux mettre en numéro 6
mois
[Musique]
je n'utilise et maintenir plaisir
au niveau national et dans les années à
venir car monter en nationale 2 après je
suis pas là encore pendant dix ans parce
que je suis assez vieux on va dire un
objectif personnel ce sera de devenir
entraîneur